sorry i'm an optician and so
i feel like you won't be able to see my
eyes
how's that that's perfect sorry
don't arrest in your program it's a slow
start
i'm fine there we go i apologize
that ar coating is just do soap and
water on it that's all
all right q yes q uh where'd you grow up
where are you from
originally originally i'm from long
beach california
i'm the only one in my family from long
beach um
the rest of my family's from back east
maryland
and tell me how you grew up you had both
your parents
well um my papa was a roll in stone and
he
um had his own separate family um
i think he left my mother when she was
pregnant with
me how would you describe your childhood
my childhood was very traumatic i am
transgender
um my mom is a bible thumper a baptist
and she goes to scripture every day
devotes
time in her morning schedule for
scripture and
i think that that's the lens that she
sees me through
um unfortunately um
so she wasn't very accepting of your of
my
femininity no at a younger age she
always tell me
why didn't you play with your boy toys
that i bought you and
why do you have your hand on your hip
and why are boys kissing you
and you know when you're gonna get a
girlfriend
and and she also at the age of nine
brought home a a father figure to boot
camp
me away from my my uh [ __ ] or
punketry or
effeminate nature which is innate
in me you were born with it i was born
this way yeah
so but um i came downtown
um to learn how to be transgender from
the girls that i met on the street
because i was doing um some screen
acting
doing background work and whatnot and i
got into the screen actors skills but
whenever i was typecasted as a
cross-dresser um
a drag queen pre-transition
um i would be called
like transsexual transvestite prostitute
like i've had that on
the side of my trailer i didn't really
understand
[Music]
what that meant until i you know to
put two and two together and it clicked
that that's
what type of women these are like late
night standing around in the corners of
you know over exaggerated attributes
and overtly feminine and beautiful
honestly and i learned how to be trans
from some girls from hollywood
but mainly downtown i've been coming
downtown since i was 18 and i i
transitioned at 23 i'm 40 years old now
um and most recently it's been
like it's i've come to the point where i
want to live
anatomically female and it's kind of
putting a wedge between my mother and
i's relationship because she's still
attached to the sun that she's never had
so um and i spent
over 10 years down here because this
is more of a prevalent area where
transgenders have been
since the 70s so this area honestly is
more acclimated
um more so than where i live which is on
39th
um close to usc
that area i did not know that i couldn't
go that far south of the 10.
i've been living there for four years
with section 8 and it's just been hectic
do you get some hard times because of
your
orientation my orientation honestly
after doing breast augmentation my life
changed drastically men
[Music]
were more drawn to me heterosexual man i
couldn't thank you as transgender until
you
yeah thank you yeah that's what happened
to me on aiden crocker i
i thought this guy knew that that's like
stanford street where all the girls had
meet and have been that way since the
70s
you know truck drivers come from east
coast over there
over here to get a good blow job let's
just say better than any
heterosexual street walking prostitute
can do
so we've been prevalent here you know
they had a hotel out here that used to
rent to us
like an apartment building and the
police don't even mess with the latino
girls that
stand out and work down in between
sevens
and paloma um some of the paloma's
seventh and
um 14th street all the way down
you're living on the street now no i got
section eight
through coordinated entry systems four
and a half years ago
but i need to move out of my apartment
because i it's been like a real culture
shock for me because i grew up in
i left long beach when i was 13 and i
grew up in santa clarita
from 13 to 19. so
it's kind of sheltered and the popular
kid and always talented i sing i dance i
act
and so i never had to deal and i've
always been an artist
and been in entertainment as far as work
is concerned as
in my adulthood after 18 but and so like
i've never
really had so much targeted like
projected um
internalized homophobia and i'm not even
a homo
so i don't even know why they do that to
me but it's like
it's out of control people like gather
outside my apartment building
and call me [ __ ] and talk about me
doing all kinds of stuff and i'm like in
the process of getting
i have letters to do free bottom surgery
but
that's not a surgery that one would want
to do for free
they're like practicing doctors that
don't really have the experience to give
you something that's functional they
make you sign like a waiver
saying that if they bought you they
don't have to fix you
and they're paying them like a hundred
thousand dollars to do that to us
and i've i came to los angeles to get
transgender health care
and take advantage of some of the
medical opportunities
so you're looking at further surgery too
yeah honestly like i don't want to be
associated with the trans community
anymore at this point because it's been
such a struggle
in los angeles trying to go back to
school
trying to integrate into the trans
community
being
[Music]
as blessed as i am with the genes that i
have in the dna that i have
not everybody's trans experience is like
mine
so i get a little you know
biological women are very competitive
but you cannot imagine how much more
competitive trans women can be when it
comes to
aesthetic and you know i'm i'm really
feminine and most people can't tell
i have to tell someone sometimes are you
taking hormones or anything like that
i am but i'm also doing sex work
so um i'm leaning back off of my
hormones right now so that i can be more
functional because impotence and
sterility and
um yeah right that comes with shrinkage
yeah that comes along with the the hrt
along with you know being prone to
cancer and
hypertension and all sorts of other
things oh really yeah
so it's complicated it is i mean now
when i ejaculate it's
clear and it smells like what would come
out of a vagina and
you know the way the porn industry
projects the image of us like
70 of those orgasms are kind of
staged i'm gonna get some come
scented lube when i'm done with your
interview
immediately so i can make some more
money
so you so you you'll work the streets
sometimes okay
it's hard to do that now because i've
i'm not in my addiction
and i i've got an opportunity to have
housing
thank god i have you know four walls and
a roof
so you're a little more stabilized i'm a
little more stabilized but i'm still
in and out of my addiction because of
the oppression
and the distortion that comes along with
people thinking that they can talk right
through you like you're transgender
you're
less human and it's i've been treated
really inhumanely
but the area is not really it's not
really like i can go
tattle on someone in the area that i
live in because that's not that kind of
area
you cannot yeah how did you want to live
yeah
and so i'm trying my best to get
myself into rehab um what's your direct
crystal meth
over the years that's i've had the most
time with crystal meth i started crystal
meth when i was 15 years old
and i'm 40 now it was it wasn't even
crystal method it was just meth
crank speed crank yeah wouldn't even
speed
crank i mean you know some people might
have called his speed but
we called it crank and [ __ ]
you know peanut butter and pink
champagne but
um i guess maybe because i'm kind of
hyper it works
on me sort of like ritalin
but honestly i've been self-destructive
because
i'm fed so much negativity in the inner
city
that far south of the tent it just
i succumbed to old habitual rituals of
self-loathing and
what keeps you from leaving that
neighborhood um
i don't have a stable job i'm on
disability right now
for mental um i have a lot of trauma
i've had a lot of attempts on my life
i'm being this effeminate
i think that's how i was able to get an
opportunity to get the housing because i
was stressing to
the caseworkers like i cannot be in the
street like
it's just you know people flip sometimes
before during and after like 50 of
african-american transgender women
will be murdered by their
african-american spouses
fifty percent of us african-american
transgender women can count on being
murdered by someone that
we've had relations with or someone that
uh has told us that
they love us and that's kind of scary
and so i lean towards sex work because
it
i don't know i'm afraid of getting
intimate with people i guess
because i feel like i've been hurt by my
mom at a young age and
when you have someone like that hurt you
at a young age it kind of
scars you a little bit do you think if
your mom was more accepting and
supportive of who you were it might have
changed
i don't even know if that's a
possibility like like i know she's
gemini
which is kind of i don't know if you
know any geminis but they have
two sides so like they can very easily
give you the illusion that like
what i've under gone with the
relationship with my mother that she's
accepting of me being her daughter now
for almost 20 years but you know
um i think out of self-preservation like
i plan on changing my name
to sever the ties and i like some of us
um transgender women look for a stealth
transition
if we're doing surgeries like that
because you know people go
way above and beyond the call of duty to
go out of their way to
out you and tell you you're just a man
you know it's like public displays of
a projected projectiled attacks
you know that they religiously or
um righteously have leeway to just
talk right to you like you not even
standing there you don't have feelings
you're inhumane my suspicious
my suspicion on men that will make those
kind of comments
is that they're turned on by it and
uncomfortable with those feelings
so that then they'll lash out like that
yeah of course
because like i see you i just i think
you're an attractive
person thank you and the fact that
you're transgender doesn't
affect me in any way yeah but i like
sword fighting
yeah but but it's it's adjusting or
fencing i just find it's interesting
that uh
so many people react so strongly to
transgenders well
i mean black brown i hate to say it
but my people and the lighter shade of
brown
it's so socially taboo for us you know
in our in our cultures in our
communities and
you know there's no even there's not
even an lgbt
center near my home you know
i have to go all the way to hollywood to
get that kind of services
there's a lot of closet cases around me
that pay a lot of attention to me and
use me
as the target even though they
you know at late night try to sneak in
my apartment or
try to talk to me on the low you know
it's like
are there a lot of straight males that
are
on the down low and well it's hard to
say
on the down low i mean what happens is
it's so socially taboo
and we are the heterosexual males best
kept secret
you know um gay men
are attracted to heterosexual males and
gay men and there's kind of like
discrimination amongst the lgbtq
ranks like some lesbians are a little
off put by us because we're like the
last ones in line to get
social acceptance and social uh equality
at this point
um like the other interview i was
telling you about like i was working
towards doing advocacy but
no one wanted me to advocate for them
because they're so envious of
my aesthetic which i haven't done
anything but breast augmentation
i was going to do some free surgeries on
my facial feminization
my body contouring um
liposuction um
and vaginoplasty and electrolysis
through insurance but
i'm looking at the girls that i don't
know
the referral lady told me that i don't
she looks at me and she doesn't think
that i need that kind of stuff
and i'm like but i have the same point
like when i look in the
mirror before i shave put tin
skin on which is like salicylic acid
razor bump solution and
schlackle on my beer coverage
oh you know like i have like my
neighbors yelling through the walls
talking about
you gotta see this [ __ ] you know
before she shaves before she puts some
makeup on it's like
what is going on like i how are you so
detached from
your own heterosexual bliss
that i'm i'm trying to like stealthily
transition into
the same kind of cookie cutter um
puppeted expectation that you
are taking for granted because you're
not even living your life or
being into your family you're like into
me and wanting to gay bash me because
you can't live your life
out in the open so bad it just upsets
that type of individual so much that
they just
project and attack and usually like
you're saying hiding a tendency
yeah it's very sad it's but they they
yeah and dangerous and i have like so
many
traumatizing events what's the worst
thing that's happened to you
um well i
was cross-dressing and i i am attracted
to heterosexual men and that's
kind of i used to like freaking tweak
with
heterosexual mens or tweak and freak i
should say i'd pick up
random men and ask them to go get
drugs for me and then while they're high
trying to have
whatever uh
table scraps that i can get left over
from biological women
you know it's my opinion about the whole
situation
it's like it seems like most of the
rejects that biological women aren't
even
spreading their legs or giving them the
time of day for some of them
come over to like what's the closest
thing to a pretty girl
and you know they don't want to they
don't want to
do the extra mile that they have to do
with heterosexual women to get their
rocks off and they just try to use us as
comm towels
and it's like this weird cyclical thing
that we have to learn to
put our foot down and save
yes or no or you know whatever
our preferences are but it's like it's a
dynamic that we play a part in
too but you know we're in the under
we're in the underbelly of
the underbelly of society and um
best kept in the shadows you know but
most of my clientele that i met street
walking and doing escorting online
and working for heidi flies even but at
one point
um but i've been back here smoking crack
behind a dumpster too
you know for five dollars so but i've
i've made like eight thousand dollars in
one day too
you know because i'm so communicative um
and pretty and good at
what i do i can vouch for the first two
the third one i'm not so sure
well you can turn off the camera and
find out maybe we'll find out later yeah
do you get depressed sometimes of course
i have highs and lows from the hrt and
interacting with people and my people
are so
mean to me like they are really really
in well in the inner city
you know i spent my summers in frederick
and mitchellsville
in maryland in the country so i didn't
really
like it's taken me a while and that 40 i
could give a [ __ ]
you know like i shouldn't have to like
take on
whatever's in your luggage and carry it
and people shouldn't
unload their luggage whatever their
issues are
into my lap like that and make me
responsible for whatever they carry
around in their bags
and so i don't know it's just
i've been shocked that i'm treated the
way that i've been treated i'm like the
class
town [ __ ] now in my almost 20th year
living every day as a woman
and having all these letters from you
know
doctors stating that i'm anatomically
female ready for vaginoplasty
and all of this and it's just it's been
really hard to stay
away from the distortion that's
constantly projected at me
so that's one of the main reasons why i
want to go back to rehab for probably
the 18th time because
over the years like it was a lot easier
to be either on the street or not at
moms
and so i'd go into rehab especially if
the weather was bad
or something because i really didn't
like staying intense i i would stay
awake
on stimulants and and then sleep for
like four or five hours at the drop in
center or in front of
fred jordan on cardboard and then or
across the way from the police station
on maple
you know find a box and get a free
blanket
or one of those wool handout blankets
that they give and
you know by the fourth hour i was
already back to the adulation
the attention the validation
pseudo validation of my womanhood which
i couldn't get anywhere else
what are your hopes and dreams for you
at this point i would love to become
like a regular joe schmoe
i i believe the hype i i want to live
the lie
that everyone else gets to i want to
puppet string myself up
and be a normal functioning member of
society but people make it
really hard like i want to cut my penis
off because i don't want my children
to have to suffer because i have a penis
between my legs
and like i see how um
awful and vindictive and
judgmental people can be how judgmental
people can be excuse me
just from you know what they can't see
which is none of their business but
you know over there by my house i have a
woman coming to the um
the store it's like 15 people families
kids in line and she's like you might be
pretty but you don't have no real [ __ ]
it's like oh my god like how would you
know what i have between my legs and why
would you
this is a 99 cent bargain store like wow
yeah they are and i'm too much of a an
empath
an uncelebrated empath i didn't grow up
with
granola family hippie family which i
wish i would have
had maybe they would have you know i
don't know
had me take reiki and become a reiki
master at 10 or something
and i could have seen myself through
different lenses instead of being like a
sensitive
negative fizzy punk
fact that needs to be you know i mean my
mom
told me at five god hurt god that she
believes in and goes to scripture
daily for and towards separate from
herself
even though i feel like in my opinion we
are all extinctions of the source
and purpose especially even us but
like if i had um
a different family maybe i don't know
like she
moved in a guy from 9 to 16 that was
like
beating the [ __ ] out of me all the time
and like one day he just said like i
know
since you don't want to do this like
you're going to get on the phone and
you're going to bring my son over here
because you don't want to play
basketball with me you don't want to i
don't know i was i was trying to figure
out
like what am i doing wrong like i always
felt like there was nothing that i could
do that would be right
you know and i was getting abused
verbally mentally and physically and my
mom was too
and she put us in that situation because
she thought that she couldn't raise the
sun
i can raise a son i can raise a woman
gender's an illusion
like we all start out female men aren't
even born they're adapted
like i just there's a glitch in my
system my brain
stayed female and my body went
the other way and so now i'm at the
place
in my life where i'm ready to fix it i
want to move to dubai
and marry my friend nina
um fishbone but i want him
he's christian his family he's from
egypt but
um he is christian and i'm sure that
it would help if i had a vagina
and not a penis between my legs um
for dubai purposing and just for
he doesn't care what i have like he'd
stick it in any orifice that i have
i do think he wants to ride my dick
though so
i think i'll just use strap-ons like i
kind of have a little shrinkage and a
little
complex from some of the abuse that my
stepdad put me through beating me up
naked and making fun of me and
chastising me about it in front of my
mom later on
did i have like a complex about my penis
and so
i uh my lady wang i'd like a wall
with lucite shelving that lights up with
like detachable
inches that would never disappoint
anyone ever again
step dad included i got weird
you know i don't know just whatever she
married the guy and everything and i i
have issues with relationships because i
watched my mom
involve herself in that in in my opinion
so that she could
de-feminize me and
i'm her only child so i could be the man
that she
wanted me to be so what would you
say is the most important thing you've
learned in your life um
wow er
tomorrow is not promised for any one of
us
and you have to live your life for
yourself like you cannot
i cannot live my life for these people
that have issues
i can't i can't like carry everyone's
baggage my luggage is
full like my louis vuittons are already
full with me and my own little baggage
like you have your own baggage and
i just need to like i'm a country girl i
think
like i'm not a city i'm not a city
slicker
i just need country living gardening
cooking for someone and
companionship normalcy
what everyone else lives to attain
towards but
it just seems like there's a certain
piece of the cake or pie that
isn't for someone like me until i get a
vagina
so i'm working towards it i'm changing
my name and you know whoever i knew
before that doesn't need to be
worried about what i did to my genitalia
because they're not going to know me i'm
changing my face change my name
but of course i have to come up with 25
000 for vaginoplasty and then however
much more for good facial uh
feminization surgery
and electrolysis a better a bigger boob
job
um you know a new location where no one
knows me and no one can say
oh here's the yearbook for this person
and
oh i know that you because i seen you
standing up over here to start a new
life
yeah just like clean slate and just
as an anatomical woman with a trans
experience
like i'd love to do that to be an eye
doctor and
have children but i don't want my
children to suffer because of the taboo
that's associated with being trans
i mean i know there's a big trans
movement but
being pretty and trans is even harder i
don't know why but
people like just the envy and jealousy
level and wanting to
i don't know maybe i'm just too
sensitive
hypersensitive like an impasse i don't
know i think you're lovely and
interesting and
thank you and beautiful so thank you
whatever you are thank you
i don't think you need to change
anything but thank you everyone's got
their thing
oh you like hybrids too no i don't know
i'm just saying as a person i think
they're both
i find you very interesting i'm just
kidding i'm not gonna ask you out for a
date but
i find you very no i'm trying it because
you're so
regally handsome and tall and well
you're well proportionate you're
beautiful but thank you there's one part
that i might have a hard time with a
hard time making it feel good
no funny no pun intended
i'll keep it tucked thank you you're
welcome
thanks for like opening up the
uh flood door for me to oh
to talk to talk about oh my god it was
fun you're so intelligent
and interesting